hey guys it's chris hemsworth day
thursday my name is Jeff I'm Dan and
here is game sweat news if you've been
worrying that your mobile games aren't
weak and pathetic enough well good news
the magic card game coming out for iOS
and Android has been released in
Magikarp jump you'll be catching magic
up training them up and as the name
implies competing in jump battles once
you're weak and pathetic Pokemon is hit
max level at 20 they'll retire and
you'll move on to a new generation of
the creature who's a little bit stronger
each new generation of Magikarp will get
stronger and stronger jumping higher and
higher and you'll be left with a real
deep understanding of the question why
like most mobile games these days magic
up jump features microtransactions for
items that assist with training leveling
and customizing your magic ops pond I
grabbed this yesterday and played it
most of last night and I have no idea
what's going on but I'm somehow so drawn
to it let me know if you're playing it
and if you can explain to me why I like
it I'd be very grateful I don't know man
then all that what Michelle on sales
talking about Beyond Good and Evil 2
online again I don't see how that's bad
you love Beyond Good and Evil yes I do
but it kind of feels like a bad
relationship at this stage Michelle on
sale keeps coming back saying oh yeah
we're still working on the game things
are gonna change is totally gonna come
out and then III after e3 we hear
nothing and this e3 is no different
unfortunately you are right on that one
but it's not all bad news last October
we got word that Beyond Good and Evil 2
is still in development but it does
still sound like we won't be seeing
anything from it anytime soon Michelle
an seller said it's not coming to e3
2017 but the team will talk about it
this year
yeah which could well be just another
confirmation that they're working hard
on it I don't know I'm getting cynical
to put this in perspective that teaser
video you're looking at now came out in
2008 that's almost 10 years ago if you
also dropped math in your senior year
like I did when I was first excited for
this game to arrive I was graduating
high school I'll never stop looking
forward to this one but then it would be
nice to see something more concrete come
of all this talking rumors another day
into this year and Microsoft is still
trying very hard to make twitch
competitor beam happen
I'll make mix happen
yeah they changed me to mixer yeah okay
co-founder Matt stelson Mindy said it
was a tough decision to change the name
but they feel like it's a better one for
the platform going forward as they
couldn't expand to all markets using the
beam name and it's not just a name
change seemingly ignoring the advice of
dr. Egon Spengler don't cross the
streams
miksa also rolled out a new co streaming
feature that allows up to four streamers
to combine their streams into one mega
stream with a centralized chat and it's
available right now for everyone on PC
and Xbox one Co streaming isn't limited
to the same game or same platform either
you can combine four streams from PC
Xbox one and mobile and there could be
someone playing Halo while someone else
is making a stew and the other two are
playing board games and they say we have
short attention spans outside of all
that mixer will be getting a page on the
Xbox one dashboard Microsoft's e3
briefings will be broadcast on mixer in
4k a mixer studio is being built at
Microsoft's 5th Avenue store in
Manhattan for quote live audience
competitive and community gaming events
and the mixer create app for iOS and
Android is up now in beta form that is
everything we've got for you today
thanks so much for joining us and
believing your comments yesterday please
do that again today if you've got any
thoughts and feelings on today's stories
happy birthday penguin gamers in ho -
and we'll see you guys